so
what do you think happens i mean maybe
uh
i'm not so much on the legal side of
things but
on the social side it's like with the
o.j simpson trial
do you think it's possible that derek
showing does not get convicted of the
what is the second degree murder
how do you think about that how do you
think about the potential social impact
of that
the the riots the protests of either
either direction any words that are said
the tension here could be explosive
especially with the cameras
yeah so yes there's certainly a
possibility that he
he'll be acquitted for homicide charges
for the jury to convict
they have to make a determination as to
officer
chovin's former officer chovin's
state of mind whether he intended
to cause some harm whether he was
grossly
reckless in causing harm
so much so that he disregarded a known
risk of death or serious bodily injury
and as you may have um read in the
papers yesterday the judge allowed a
a third degree murder charge in kentucky
which uh is uh cons it's
the mindset the state of mind uh there
is not an intention
uh but it's a depraved indifference
uh and what that means is that the jury
doesn't have to find that he intended to
do anything
uh rather they could find that he was
just
indifferent to a risk
that's dark yeah yeah i'm not sure
what's worse
yeah well that's that's a good point but
uh but but it's another basis for the
jury
uh to convict but but look you never
know what what happens when you go to
jury trial so there could be
a um an acquittal
and if there is i imagine there would be
massive uh
protests uh if he's convicted
i i i don't think that would happen
uh because i just don't see at least
nothing i've seen or read suggest that
there's a
a big pro uh chauvin camp out there
ready to protest
well there could be a is there also uh
potential tensions that could arise from
the sentencing
i don't know how that exactly works sort
of not enough years kind of thing
yeah it could be like all that kind of
yeah i a lot could happen
so it depends on what he's convicted of
uh you know one count i think is
like up to 10 years another counts up to
40 years
uh so it depends what he's convicted of
and yes it depends on how much
of the how much time the judge gives him
if he is convicted
uh that there's a lot of space for
people to be very angry and so we will
we will see what happens i just feel
like with the judge
and and the lawyers there's an
opportunity to have
really important long-lasting speeches
i don't know if they think of it that
way especially with the cameras
it it feels like they have the capacity
to heal or to divide um do you ever
think about that
as a as a lawyer as a legal mind
that your words aren't just about the
case but about the
they'll reverberate through history
potentially
um that is that is certainly a
possible consequence of things you say
i don't think that most lawyers think
about that
in the context of the case uh your role
is much more
narrow uh you're the partisan advocate
as a defense lawyer partisan advocate
for
uh that client as a prosecutor you're a
minister of justice
attempting to prosecute that particular
case but the reality is
you are absolutely correct that
sometimes the things you say
will have a shelf life
you